en côte d'ivoire les investitures pour
la présidentielle du 31 octobre se
poursuivre
l'ex premier ministre guillaume soro
doit être investi tout à l'heure par son
mouvement générations et peuples
solidaires
l'ancien président henri konan-bédié à
lui officiellement été investi hier par
son parti le pdci-rda
ce dernier dénonce la candidature de
l'actuel chef de l'état qui brigue un
troisième mandat
mercure contre alassane ouattara ont été
déposés par l'opposition devant le
conseil constitutionnel
les sociologues de rodrigues connaît
doutent de l'efficacité de ces
procédures
l'opposition essaie de se mobiliser pour
pouvoir contrecarrer cette candidature
d'alassane ouattara mais qui semble être
un acteur bien positionné dans le conte
est comparativement au présent ib cas
qui avait cette forte contestation de
plus longtemps et ici c'est une partie
de la population qui compte est que sa
candidature est et il a ses partisans et
donc nous sommes dans un jeu de rapports
de force entre une opposition qui est en
train de se structurer de renforcer son
positionnement à mobiliser la rue est un
parti au pouvoir qui tient la machine
l'appareil d'état l'histoire nous
enseigne que à chaque fois le conseil
constitutionnel et ses grandes décisions
qui sont plus proches du pouvoir que de
l'opposition que celle de l'opposition
donc le sang peut être présager de ce
qui sera dit il est fort probable que le
conseil constitutionnel puisse valider
la candidature de monsieur alassane